el descontento en Francia por la reforma
de pensiones es patente los grupos
sindicales la consideran un retroceso
del estado de bienestar pero Qué incluye
esta polémica reforma prevé aumentar la
edad de jubilación de los 62 años a los
64 además de los años de cotización
necesarios para acceder a una pensión
completa que pasarán de 42 a 43 años
trabajados a cambio el gobierno
prometido aumentar a 1.200 euros en la
pensión mínima y facilitar las
prejubilaciones algo que tanto
sindicalistas como expertos consideran
insuficiente no hay ganadores en esta
reforma los perdedores son la clase
media y la clase media baja sobre todo
aquellos que han empezado relativamente
pronto a trabajar que tendrán que
trabajar aún más o los que no han tenido
posibilidad de tener una carrera
completa y Perdieron el trabajo entre
los 55 y los 58 años y aún así tienen
que esperar más para cobrar la pensión
el argumento del gobierno para estos
cambios evitar el endeudamiento
progresivo del sistema Público de
pensiones que se prevé de 13.500
millones de euros para 2030 Y es que el
envejecimiento de la población es un
problema largo plazo ya que son los
trabajadores en activo los que pagan las
pensiones no obstante los trabajadores
aseguran que hay otras formas de mermar
la deuda Como subir los impuestos a las
empresas de más ingresos o aumentar el
porcentaje de cotización la
intersindical pide una pensión a una
edad que permita vivir dignamente entre
algunas de sus demandas La retirada
inmediata de la Reforma pensiones
mínimas de la media del salario
vitalicio acordes a la evolución del
costo de vida e igual entre hombres y
mujeres además de un aumento inmediato
del 10% de los salarios para compensar
la pérdida de poder adquisitivo desde
2015 la reforma actual es más dura que
la abortada en 2020 y de seguir adelante
el consejo de orientación de los
jubilados estima que los pensionistas
podrían perder un 20% de poder
adquisitivo